so there's this common myth that we all
need six to eight hours of sleep but I
sat down with a neuroscientist who told
me that we can't generalize and six to
eight hours might not actually be enough
for you so how do you know if you're not
getting enough sleep do you need a
partner or an alarm clock to wake you up
in the morning does it take you a long
time to wake up do you crave caffeinated
and sugar-rich drinks during the day to
keep you awake have your friends family
colleagues reported that you're showing
a lack of empathy increased frustration
they may have noticed that you do stupid
and unreflective things and when given
the opportunities to sleep let's say at
the weekend do you find your sleep
patterns change there are subtle changes
which can make you a morning person or
an evening person but also going back to
light that can contribute to what's
called your chronotype your morningness
and eveningness so morning light
advances the clock makes you get up
earlier evening light delays the clock
makes you get up later and go to bed